WITH IVANKA TRUMP WHO SAT DOWN
WITH GLORIA BORGER.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
FATHER AS A PARENT GROWING UP?
>> HE WAS AN INCREDIBLE PARENT
AND IS AN INCREDIBLE PARENT,
THAT I THINK I APPRECIATED MUCH
MORE TODAY AS A PARENT OF THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
I THINK WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER I
THOUGHT PARENTING WAS JUST
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS, AND NOW
I REALIZE HOW MUCH WORK GOES
INTO RAISING KIDS WITH A SENSE
OF PURPOSE AND WORK ETHIC AND --
AND RAISING THEM TO BE CLOSE TO
ONE ANOTHER AND OBVIOUSLY, TO
STAY CLOSE TO THEIR PARENTS.
SO I -- I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
HIM AND MY MOTHER, AND ALL THAT
THEY DID FOR US AS CHILDREN AND
ALL THAT THEY CONTINUE TO DO FOR
US TODAY, BUT YOU KNOW, HE WAS
THE SAME TYPE OF PARENT AS WE
SEE GENERALLY.
HE WAS FUNNY, SOMETIMES WICKEDLY
SO.
GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR.
HE -- HE WAS DEMANDING OF US.
HE HAD VERY HIGH EXPECTATIONS
FOR US BECAUSE HE KNEW WHAT WE
HAD THE POTENTIAL TO ACCOMPLISH,
AND HE SAW THE POTENTIAL IN US
BEFORE WE SAW IT IN OURSELVES,
AND I THINK REALLY ENCOURAGED US
TO PURSUE OUR PASSIONS.
HE WANTED US TO FIND MEANING AND
PURPOSE IN OUR LIVES, BUT WAS
VERY CAREFUL NOT TO PUSH US INTO
REAL ESTATE.
SO I THINK THAT'S PARTIALLY
BECAUSE HIS EXCITEMENT, HIS
PASSION FOR REAL ESTATE AND
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID HE
BROUGHT HOME, AND SO I THINK WE
INHERITED A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
EXCITEMENT AND PERHAPS IT'S IN
THE BLOOD, BUT HE ALWAYS SAID TO
US YOU HAVE TO DO WHAT YOU'LL
LOVE AND YOU'LL NEVER SUCCEED,
YOU'LL NEVER BE ABLE TO COMPETE
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL IF YOU
DON'T DEEPLY LOVE WHAT IT IS
WHAT YOU DO.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO GET OUT OF
BED AND DO WHAT IT IS THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND IT'S PROBABLY
MOST CONSISTENTLY PIECE OF
ADVICE HE GAVE ME MY WHOLE LIFE
AND HE WOULD PERIODICALLY CHECK
IN WITH ME AND ALMOST UNDERMINE
MY THOUGHT PROCESS ABOUT COMING
INTO THE FAMILY BUSINESS BECAUSE
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
KNEW THAT IT WASN'T AN
EXPECTATION OF HIS.
>> SO WHEN YOU WERE YOUNG WAS
YOUR DAD SORT OF THE KIND OF A
DAD WHO WOULD PLAY GAMES WITH
YOU, READ YOUR BEDTIME STORIES
OR DIFFERENT THAN THAT?
>> NO.
HE WAS DIFFERENT.
HE WAS NOT REALLY THE TYPE OF --
HE WASN'T LONG ON DIAPER
CHANGING AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
BUT YOU KNOW, HE ON EYE THINK
MAYBE HE WAS A LITTLE BIT MORE
TRADITIONAL IN THAT REGARD, BUT
HE WAS VERY ACCESSIBLE AND VERY
AVAILABLE, AND I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK ABOUT SO
OFTEN IS THAT I NEVER QUESTIONED
THAT MY SIBLINGS AND I WERE HIS
TOP PRIORITY.
HE NEVER ALLOWED US TO.
HE NEVER ALLOWED US TO QUESTION
THAT FACT BECAUSE HE ALWAYS MADE
US HIS TOP PRIORITY.
IT DIDN'T MEAN HE WAS HOME EVERY
NIGHT FOR DINNER.
HE WASN'T.
HE WAS WORKING VERY HARD AND HE
WAS BUILDING AN ENORMOUS
BUSINESS AND HE WAS IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF DOING THAT WHEN I WAS
YOUNG AND HAD A LOT TO PROVE TO
HIMSELF AND TO OTHERS, AND HE
HAD BIG AMBITIONS FOR HIMSELF.
HE WASN'T ALWAYS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT, BUT HE WAS ALWAYS
AVAILABLE.
AS A LITTLE GIRL A FRIEND OF
MINE REMINDED ME ABOUT THIS
RECENTLY, THAT SHE USED TO HANG
OUT WITH ME IN A JANITOR'S
CLOSET WHERE THERE WAS A PAY
PHONE AT SCHOOL, AND ON RECESS I
WOULD GO THERE AND I'D CALL
COLLECT TO HIS OFFICE.
I WAS PROBABLY 10 YEARS OLD, AND
I WOULD CALL COLLECT TO THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION WHICH IS
HILARIOUS --?
AND YOU'D SAY HI, THIS IS
IVANKA?
>> FROM THE SCHOOL, AND HE WOULD
PICK UP THE PHONE EVERY SINGLE
TIME AND HE'D PUT ME ON SPEAKER
PHONE.
IT WOULD AREN'T BE A LONG
CONVERSATION AND HE'D INTRODUCE
ME TO WHOEVER WAS IN HIS OFFICE,
BUT ONLY IN RETROSPECT NOW IT
DIDN'T MATTER WHO WAS THERE, IT
WAS COLLEAGUES, IT WAS TITANS OF
INDUSTRY.
IT WAS HEADS OF COUNTRY, HE
WOULD ALWAYS TAKE MY CALL, AND
HE'D ALWAYS TELL EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM HOW GREAT A DAUGHTER I WAS
AND SAY CUTE THINGS AND ASK ME
ABOUT A TEST I TOOK, BUT YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT'S REALLY
TELLING OF HIM AS A PERSON AND A
PARENT.
WE ALWAYS CAME FIRST.
>> HOW ABOUT WHEN YOU BROUGHT
HOME A DATE OR A BOYFRIEND?
>> I WAS TOO SMART TO BRING HOME
A DATE OR A BOYFRIEND.
I THINK I BROUGHT HOME MY
HUSBAND.
THAT'S IT.
>> A LITTLE INTIMIDATING?
>> MY HUSBAND, WHEN I BROUGHT
HIM HOME, BUT I WAS NOT GOING TO
SUBJECT BOYFRIENDS TO THE
SCRUTINY OF MY FATHER OR MOTHER,
FOR THAT MATTER, UNLESS I WAS
100% SURE.
>> AND LET ME MOVE ON NOW TO THE
CAMPAIGN A LITTLE BIT.
YOUR FATHER HAS SAID THAT YOU
AND MELANIA HAD WANTED HIM TO BE
MORE PRESIDENTIAL IS THE WORD
THAT HE USES.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT BECAUSE DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THE NICKNAMES
HE USED FOR SOME PEOPLE OR THE
NAME CALLING WAS A MISTAKE?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN YOU SAY MORE
PRESIDENTIAL?
>> WELL, YOU WOULD -- MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY FATHER ARE
REALLY BETWEEN US, BUT OBVIOUSLY
I'M HIS CHILD, AND I ALSO HAVE
BEEN HIS COLLEAGUE, AND I'VE
WORKED ALONGSIDE OF HIM FOR THE
PAST DECADE HERE AT THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, AND PART OF THE
REASON WE HAVE SUCH A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP IS BECAUSE HE
RESPECTS ME, AND BECAUSE I'M
CANDID IN MY OPINIONS, AND I
SHARE THEM, SOLICITED OR
OTHERWISE.
>> BUT TO THAT QUESTION, I MEAN,
DO YOU THINK THOSE WERE -- DID
YOU TELL HIM THOSE WERE A
MISTAKE OR YOU DON'T?
>> WELL, ONCE IN A WHILE HE'LL
SAY THINGS AND I'LL TELL HIM HE
COULD DO WITH RATCHETING IT
BACK.
>> AND HE LISTENS.
>> SOMETIMES AND SOMETIMES HE
DOESN'T AND SOMETIMES HE LISTENS
FOR LIMITED PERIODS OF TIME.
>> BUT YOU CAN TELL HIM.
>> THINK IT'S PART OF WHAT
PEOPLE LOVE ABOUT HIM.
IT'S ALSO WHAT PART OF WHAT
ANGERS PEOPLE.
HE IS AUTHENTIC.
YOU KNOW, NOBODY TELLS HIM WHO
TO BE.
HE IS HIMSELF.
HE IS HIS OWN MAN.
HE LISTENS TO THE OPINIONS OF
OTHER PS UPON HE RESPECTS THE
OPINIONS OF OTHERS AND HE
PROCESSES THE ADVICE PEOPLE GIVE
HIM AND ULTIMATELY HE MAKES HIS
OWN DECISIONS.
>> HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THE
DONALD TRUMP YOU KNOW AS YOUR
DAD WITH THE CANDIDATE THAT SOME
PEOPLE SEE AND CONSIDER SO
DIVISIVE?
HOW DO YOU SQUARE THAT -- THAT
CIRCLE FOR OUR VIEWERS?
>> MY FATHER HAS ALWAYS ELICITED
STRONG OPINIONS IN PEOPLE.
HE IS BOLD.
HE IS UNABASHED.
HE IS VERY HIMSELF, AND I THINK
FOR ME, THE ULTIMATE -- THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING, IF I KNOW THE
MAN, SO WHEN I HEAR THINGS THAT
ARE FACTUALLY INACCURATE, IT'S
SOMETIMES HURTFUL.
I FEEL THAT AS A DAUGHTER, BUT I
STILL KNOW THE MAN.
I -- I, AS A WOMAN, I AS A
PERSON, COULD NEVER SUPPORT
SOMEONE WHO WAS SEXIST OR
RACIST, BUT I JUST COULDN'T.
I -- I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
OKAY WITH THAT, BUT I KNOW WHO
HE IS AS A HUMAN BEING, AND I
KNOW THOSE THINGS ARE NOT TRUE,
AND NOT MANY PEOPLE SAY THOSE
THING,